back here on the rich eisen show it's
been quite some time since he visited us
in person he's got a couple of projects
to talk about right here paramount
pluses mayor of kingstown sunday
november 14th is when that's going to
premiere and then hawkeye debuting on
disney plus on november 24th everybody
knows about hawkeye and what uh what
this is all gonna be about we will talk
about it it's always a plus to have this
man on the show on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line die hard 49er fan jeremy
renner back here on the show how you
been jeremy hey
been very good very busy i
clearly yeah very very much so all right
let's just jump right into it um how
concerned are you about your 49ers
jeremy let's just i am very very i mean
come on man it's like well he's always
with injuries right and that's always
doesn't help help matters right with any
team
but uh you know i always feel like you
know they
i love the team i love you know the
coaching i love everything that's going
on but when you don't have all your
players you know
playing you know you gotta you got a
running team and you don't have the your
running backs that stuff that's tough
you know
first stringers when they go out all
right well as that is right but you know
when you love a team you love the team
and you know you gotta take the go with
the bat
that's what happened and you're you're
you're originally from modesto is that
is that correct yeah yeah right yeah so
okay i know i've been watching since
1979. ah did you go to candlestick as a
kid
did you oh yeah this deck yeah yeah okay
yeah i did i don't know may it rest in
peace right or pieces yeah that's right
back in the day yeah
oh my gosh now it's levi right there in
beautiful santa clara california down
the road uh yeah so who's your guy
growing up for the 49ers jeremy who was
your guy well that was you know the era
when uh
walsh and
montana and rice and all that all that
started happening right became what um
and like the patriots ended up looking
like you know as a recent that kind of
giant franchise that uh
that that wall shaped and
became what the niners were back then is
tremendous wouldn't it yeah of course i
mean montana rice the both super bowls
are against the hapless bengals in that
regard you know
cincinnati every single time they
made the super bowl in their history
they ran it to joe montana and bill
walsh yeah that would call that would we
would call that a problem in the
football world yeah yeah we would call
that an absolute problem but
so uh and and you did if i'm not
mistaken because i heard your voice on
nfl network in recent days you did you
voiced the documentary for the the two
cities right that was born out of the
catch
with dwight clark that was your voice
yeah correct correct yeah that was that
was awesome they got open to open the
stadium as well that was awesome man it
was great to be kind of part of that
team and that franchise and in a
different way just as a spectator um
those are wonderful opportunities you
know i love it jeremy renner here on the
rich eisen show um the uh star of the
mayor of kingstown which is going to be
premiering on paramount plus
sunday november 14th and then hawkeye
that debuts on disney plus on november
24th what can you reveal for die hard
fans of the marvel universe
uh that that hawkeye is to feature what
can you
always never never enough and not enough
for uh about those things but you know
it is a
quite a holiday event um for sure
because it takes place during a specific
time and
and uh in new york and it is all during
the holidays so and that's kind of been
shown in the trailer uh the big the
biggest thing that comes out and it's
not a shock or surprise because it is uh
promoted that there's a female hawkeye
people haley steinfeld who's tremendous
i've heard of her she comes into the
picture to um
to help uh the process along and uh it's
gonna be uh fine if we shoot we shot it
like a six-hour film
uh even though it'll be episodic the
first two episodes will air on the 24th
and it'll play all the way up until
christmas
and um
it'll be you know part of the holiday uh
season and it certainly is part of uh
the show
um the holidays and that spirit yeah my
kids can't wait to be very honest with
you yeah and by the way i can't this is
gonna be the first thing i get to watch
with my daughter
uh because she's never seen anything
i've done thus far she's eight years old
right now she's age-appropriate to be
able to watch this and so i'm actually
really excited to be able to sit with my
family and my daughter and actually she
can see what daddy does for a living she
hasn't seen her locker is that what
you're saying jeremy she hasn't checked
out
yeah it's about baseball i mean in a way
no you can't do that so that's cool so
you'll sit down okay
and and how do you think she'll take it
jeremy i think she i think she'll dig it
i mean she knows that i'm hawkeye except
my face is on her pajamas
but he's never seen holy wood you know
hawkeye has a bow and arrow
yes okay that's cool that'll be so cool
fantastic that'll be great for you
perfect holidays
shoes because she was there on on set
for a lot of it so she'll
even when she saw the trailer she's like
oh i remember that as being there on
jared she gets a little bit more
involved which is which is always a good
thing it's not quite such a separate
world now that's pretty much
in daddy life so very good and then
obviously on the completely opposite
side of that spectrum um is marriage i
think you can't watch kingstown
you will not be watching yeah
uh and this this looks really intense uh
jeremy to say to say the least about um
a town in michigan uh where
incarceration is an industry and um and
kyle chandler who i love from friday
night lights just so many fans of this
show might know him from uh deanne wiest
and the rest of this cast what uh and
aidan gillen who is great in everything
that he does from
the wire to uh game of thrones
what do you what do you have
what do you uh want folks to know about
this project that comes out before yeah
this is just like a very kind of um
if i could use the town as a reference
the town is you know based about this
charlestown thing that the environment
really dictates just these little
microcosm communities like this
community is a
is built around a bunch of prisons
and the main business
in this town and jobs in this town is
about incarceration
and so it's either you're inside the
prison or outside the prison and there's
jobs that revolve around it and the
character um
the mayor
if you will
his job ultimately is to keep peace his
initial job is is
for out for inmate outreach to to be
able to be a voice for the the prisoners
um he's he was a prisoner himself and
she has connections with all the gang
leaders and knows all the prison guards
and the thing and all his job is to be
the grease of the engine of the business
of incarceration just trying to keep
peace in this town where there seems to
be a little hope
uh
pretty much so you know he's just trying
to keep the peace between people and
that again that's going to be on
paramount plus on sunday november 14th
in the premiere hawkeye uh will be a
family affair um during the holiday
season jeremy there's a couple of uh we
we like to play with our celebrity
guests every now and then celebrity true
or false about things that that are out
there either in your filmography or on
stories and features about you that we
were wondering if we're true or false
would you mind playing that with us here
over the next okay here we go there's
jeremy renner here celebrity true or
false on the rich eisen show we gotta
even
celebrity true or false you can't handle
the truth
that's called production value jeremy
that's called production value right
there okay
first one up uh is it true or false
celebrity true or false that you worked
as a makeup artist early in your career
is that true or false uh is that very
true okay um
where what how i guess is there the
surroundings yeah it was a job i had in
my small town in modesto i was able to
take down into la and have a job and i
worked uh
at like lancome cosmetics at the at all
the malls from
la down to san diego on the weekends and
did like color events and things like
that
so um
in a pinch can you can you can you fill
in sometimes
yeah i have i have in a lot of ways yeah
okay great i i love the job it's a great
trade because i gotta learn about
there's a little more the psychology of
makeup and stuff with why i like it so
much
i did so well in it um applying it is i
think quite easy but um i just love more
you know how do you make someone feel
uh beautiful and it has something to do
to make it it's i think it's about just
being when it's understood and okay um
like the the beauty is from what's
inside and not from just just makeup
look at you man that just you must have
been very popular you must have been
very popular
i mean not only making them beautiful
outside but you know talking to them
during that i mean that must have been
quite a run for you jeremy yeah it was
it was it made me feel good okay i
couldn't sell make up for help
but because because i did well as how i
did makeup yes people bought what i put
on them okay very good terrific uh next
one this is interesting i'll i'll just
come out and say it uh because this
leapt out at us and not to borrow a
phrase uh true or false that you once
accidentally took viagra on a
transatlantic flight jeremy renner is
that true or false yeah yeah that's true
there's supposed to be a sleeping pill
there's supposed to be an ambien yeah
right and on the pill it looked like an
a
and yeah
it was not you turn it upside down as a
v
and so
it was
something really quite serious i don't
like to take any kind of
driving united stick aspirin right but i
really need to get some sleep because i
flew into la to meet catherine bigelow
to
for the hurt lockers
got to work
to london yeah and as soon as i got off
the plane had to go to work so i had to
sleep so i got zero sleep
and so i was desperate so i had i
scrambled scrambled around and someone
said hey i got an ambient light okay
great i'll take it and then it'll be a
fire so not only did i not sleep
i said i had a friend that was awake
with me it was awful
it was the worst thing and they became
such a joke on the plane the
stewardesses were like they kind of
didn't feel bad for me i just asked him
for ice like what do you got and he's
jumping
it was one of the worst experiences
so you shared you shared or was just i
mean i don't know how detailed we can
get here because you're obviously the
seat wasn't the only thing in the
upright position uh hey now
you know i've been all the jokes on that
one but it's like yeah it's really quite
awful it's embarrassing uh then it just
became a joke and you know that made it
less embarrassing once everyone was in
on the joke okay um but again it was a
night fight so think thankfully um
everyone was asleep okay uh did that
help okay and uh dennis hopper was
actually in god rest his soul uh he was
he was uh next to me come on are you
serious
get out of here yeah but he was asleep
but his daughter was awake
and i'm like oh god
now i'm back in the uncomfortable mode
i'm like how it was yeah it was very
very very embarrassing oh my god uh god
what was hopper like just in real life
outside all this what was he like he was
pretty much he was again it was a like a
red eye everyone's already asleep on the
flight yeah
right
no it's about but for me so so did you
not know you just by happenstance sat
next to him or you just you knew
yeah
that is the most random story i've ever
heard oh man yeah yeah there's a strange
one but again it was
hard for me to remember that that even
happened because i was so worried about
you know
my situation yes you're sitting well
well put uh a couple left for you here
jeremy renner celebrity true or false
this is this is lit as the kids say uh
true or false you studied criminology in
college before getting the acting bug is
that a true story yes
yes yes you know i had to pick a major
and that was one i one of the second
ones i jumped into because i thought it
was interesting
um yeah that was a there's more about
the psychological part of criminology
um
okay than anything else so you've done
criminal you you you you you've done
criminology and makeup artists and
acting i mean you've been all over the
map this is impressive jeremy i gotta be
honest with you that's very impressive
okay
i got last one for you true or false
you're filming the shootout scene in the
town okay yes and somebody in the
neighborhood comes outside to complain
about being woken up early in the
morning and true or false it turned out
to be former red sox closer jonathan
papelbon complaining about it true or
false
uh that i don't know i can't say true or
false i mean for me i i guess if i had
to say it wouldn't be false but because
i don't know that
i mean it isn't someone knows about it i
never heard of it apparently he wanted
you to close the scene he wanted to
close everything down from what it from
imagine i mean i know that happened i
knew yeah we were disruptive in
neighborhoods because
of the nature of that uh the scene the
car chases and all that stuff right
there's a lot of stuff but we also had
ben who's kind of considered the kind of
prince of boston and the pride of that
and
you know i'm sure there's a lot of
strange instances that happen
i mean don't worry about making confirm
or deny that that happened to
to to that guy okay so jonathan pablo so
yeah so uh
so it doesn't matter just make as much
of a ruckus by the way if he did come
out they probably would have put him in
the film i bet
i bet but i love that it's just like
done i love that though it's just like
make as much noise as you want scare as
many people with those crazy ass masks
as you want because because because uh
affleck will smooth it all over in the
very end because he's got that yeah yeah
yeah i know they'll put him a costume
and they'll put him in a mask
put him to work
jeremy this has been a blast man um uh
good luck with everything mayor of
kingstown on paramount plus um coming up
in the middle of november and enjoy
watching um hawkeye with your daughter
uh i'll enjoy watching it with my kids
man i look forward to that yeah yeah i
can't wait exciting time thanks jeremy
you take care of yourself let's do this
again that's jeremyrenner jeremyrenner
on twitter and instagram the highly
popular jeremy renner right here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here